the Left Right Paradigm people used to
say I'm left I'm right well because
everything has become Niche due to the
internet what you see is political
movements becoming fractured and
fragmented and it at first it happened
with the left where I originally was on
the left and then I saw wokism and we
all know what happened with that but now
I'm seeing on the right and the
fractures start to appear on the right
so so what do you think of that what's
happening on the right and where do you
place yourself yeah it's it's a tough
one I mean if you ask me that maybe a
year or two ago I'd probably have like a
you know a name for the place where I
place myself but now I'm not so sure
just because I've I'm kind of in the
more kind of dissident right right wing
space and I kind of know the different
factions now and it does feel like it's
the fracturing is more of a product of
what's going on with the medium itself
like with the internet itself and the
incentives that are set by the platforms
obviously you know what what are these
movements they all are they have a few
key influencers some of them and they
kind of set policy for the movements and
to grow your specific Circle you kind of
have to cleave off audience from the
other circles and then you enter into
these beefs for whatever point of
Doctrine you know there's beef around
you know should we be a wife guy or is
you know women loving loving women and
having a peaceful home with them gay you
know or something like that what a
conversation this is this is an
important conversation on the right
obviously there's a split between
um religious and atheist right-wingers
or people who are like maybe more into
like the Pagan Vibes and things like
that that's a big fault line so you know
that that's kind of you know and
obviously the the influencers in these
in these spaces especially because now
there's more attention to these space
because there really is a lot of you
know generative interesting stuff
happening there that's why I'm in the
space
um they're getting a lot of attention
you know there's a bit of money actually
people are getting of whatever signups
and whatever sub stack money
um and yeah there's more in incentive to
to present yourself as you know the the
actual air of the right wing in general
and this is the program and my ten point
program is much more coherent than your
10 point program and yeah people
fighting about over immigration like
there's a the major fault line now is uh
between people who are um kind of
Christian and they're essentially
looking forward to you know a right wing
with kind of a Christian core as kind of
the morality of whatever proposed state
that they'd like to live in
um and people who say oh no Christianity
essentially it just means you know open
borders because you just let in anyone
in the world who's Christian and that
obviously has a lot of you know bad side
effects in the sense that where it's
pretty much a square one and we have the
same social ills that we have now but
everyone's nominally Christian so yeah I
mean that's kind of the the main divide
here and I I there is something to these
arguments obviously they need to be to
be discussed but the fact that they end
up you know in the sense that okay we
need to purge you you know you need to
we need to cleave you off and we need to
whoever is with me has to stay on this
side of the fence and whoever is not
with me needs to leave it's um yeah it's
definitely a it's a
interesting and Lively time to be and
and right-wing Politics on the internet
um but yeah it's still it's still I
think one of the most interesting places
to to hang out
um and you identify as being to quote
your words a dissident right uh what
what does that actually mean what do you
believe it's a moniker for the whole the
whole space I mean what do I believe I
mean I've you know I don't think I've
I'd say I have like a you know political
program to implement tomorrow but I'm
definitely I'm more of a kind of a
suspicious of of
um mainstream right politics I mean I
share the same values I mean I think we
should have a society that has kind of a
relatively core normative ideas of of
how to live life you know the the two
family types two parent family type
situation and that policy should be
geared towards supporting that and you
know we should be having a kind of a
long-term consideration of what our
societies will look like which brings in
the kind of the birth rates conversation
and all of this stuff
um I think religion should have a of
kind of a revered position in society
though you know my personal relationship
with religion's a little bit tortured
and I know but um yeah I think you know
I'm kind of right-wing in the sense of
yes my values aligned with pretty much I
would say most right-wing people who
would consider themselves right-wing
what the decision right brings to the
table is kind of um a more
granular critique of power like a lot of
people in the distance wouldn't say that
you know okay we just need to win the
next election because I think the the
main Epiphany that they've had is
post-trump post-brexit is that things
just don't work that way you know it's
not like you win an election and you
have power and your side has power and
now you do your your side's things
um we discovered that you know there is
a whole substructure kind of managerial
substructure you call it the blob call
it the cathedral call it whatever you'd
like
um that um essentially has a as a mind
of its own and it is fueled by status
it's fueled by what the elite the actual
Elite who's in power not the figurehead
guy who you voted in or out
um and uh what what they believe and
what what fuels them and what interests
them and for now the major
um kind of ideology behind the elite is
some form of wokeness you know the most
interesting and powerful people in the
world believe some form of wokeness of
either because they are True Believers
but I think most of them are or because
it is useful to them because it has you
know some useful characteristics for uh
for the upper class because they can
essentially have kind of this very
profound moral Vision where they can not
only feel good about themselves for you
know flagellating themselves because you
know whatever white guilt and all this
type of stuff they can hate the people
that they usually hate which is kind of
the middle and lower middle class and
then they can also kind of virtuously
give handouts to their client classes
which are the lower classes you know
people immigrants you know all the the
world Coalition the world pyramid that
you want to uh
obviously they don't mingle with these
people but they are their client class
and they can make promises to them and
they can gang up on the middle obviously
because the middle is always the
contender for the top spot you know
you're not worried about you know the
people in New them you know you're
worried about the people in Cornwall you
know and you don't want those to come in
and get you
foreign